there is no minimalist rule book
well until now the minimalists have
created
16 rules for living with less
a free ebook which you can download
right now
at theminimalists.com resources enjoy
non-minimalists so apparently we're
authors podcasters filmmakers public
speakers when we started this
10 years ago this this the minimalist it
wasn't even a business then we didn't
we weren't registered as a business it
was a domain right
it was a blog right and in fact we
didn't know it was called a blog when we
first started it and this has been the
joke ever since like we always called a
website we called them essays because we
didn't know
they were blog posts because i had read
essays and i'm like okay i've never
written essays but
do you velicalis essayists yeah yeah i
think great
so probably no maybe it used to say that
or somewhere
i've read that we were essayists
somewhere interesting uh yeah
anyway i wasn't a public speaker yet
although i
i was a private public speaker meaning
the
for the last eight or nine years
previous to the website i had been
it's one of the reasons i got promoted
so high in the company
is i started doing i was the first
person to do this i
started doing the monthly what we called
promo pack it was like
yeah i would get up and give a hour-long
talk in front of an entire well first it
was a store
and then it was a region of stores and
it was multiple regions of stores
yeah and i would get up in front of all
those people and the first time i did it
you were there and oh yeah this was
2000 was that in the kentucky store no
we were in westchester
oh okay westchester ohio and i
i had to speak in front of eight of my
ten employees because eight of you
showed up
and i had to give and i was terrified
ryan oh yeah i'd never
spoken in front of eight people before
but now i can speak in front of 15 000
people we've done that we did it last
year
yeah um and i'm not nearly as terrified
as when i was speaking in front of those
eight it was building up that muscle of
speed and
it was i'm sure it was terrible even
though i practiced a lot
and and prepared but i got better and
better and better through
doing those rounds i was doing it every
month several times a month speaking in
front of large crowds of people in the
corporate world
taking the initiative taking it on not
being asked to do it but saying hey
can i do this for everyone and not
knowing that that skill would come in
really handy because you and i have gone
in
on nine tours in the last 10 years right
we've spoken in front of hundreds of
thousands of people at this point i had
to learn the really hard way my my first
promo pack reading
uh you even told me you were like dude
the way you do the promo pack reading is
you read it the night before you fill in
all the blanks because
so for the people who listening to this
a promo pack reading is you
meet at the beginning of the month and
you go over all the promotions for that
month right
and the way we made a game of it where
it was like
fill in the blank with certain uh
with certain promos and if they could
guess the correct
answer that went into the blank then we
would like give them prizes and stuff
so you're telling me read it the night
before and i was like i don't need to
read it like i'll be
fine and i think i went out partying and
like probably got like three hours
of sleep that night and i came in the
next day and it was awful man it was so
bad like
i remember because you had left you had
left
the uh yeah you were when i did it you
uh you were already gone i left the date
in stores or
no i think you oh maybe oh you know what
no yeah maybe you just left the date in
stores yeah maybe you were down you were
working downtown at that time
but i just remember um doing it
uh failing and then afterwards i went up
to stan dukes and i was like uh
he was like you know josh milburn
i'll never forget that
but anyway it was a hard lesson in um
public speaking uh i'm grateful for that
lesson because
it has made me take practicing very
seriously
in fact over practicing is that where
i'm at now
yeah and i think we we do over practice
now for whenever we got in tour like we
spend so much time in conference rooms
going over and over and over and over
for
weeks and weeks and weeks preparing so
if you've ever come to one of our tour
stops and seen us give a talk
that that whatever talk you saw was many
many many
hours yeah hundreds of hours of practice
yeah
my uh my public speech you know
one-on-one class was basically like for
every minute your talk is
you need to at least practice an hour
and i probably do four hours
yeah for each minute i believe that at
least yeah at least
now uh ryan so we are authors podcasters
filmmakers public speakers we just
talked about the public speaking thing
that was unintentional we went on our
first tour 2011
and we've been on nine tours since then
and that first tour though was just a
meet up tour and we weren't really
like we occasionally get up and and and
kind of give an impromptu talk
but what we learned from that was 33
cities yeah
what we learned from that was
listening to what resonated so
i thought we both thought the packing
party was actually kind of a
i don't want to say a throwaway idea but
it was like yeah we already talked about
we put up on the web
website let's move on yeah but people
kept asking about the packing party over
and over and over i'm like
really it's it's boxes and but i
understand it now but at the time i was
like oh
like it didn't it didn't and there were
all these things i thought would
resonate with me
yeah ryan i wrote this essay about
channel surfing oh yeah and
it's still one of my favorite things but
i it hasn't resonated it didn't work
then it hasn't worked i in fact i even
tried to put a new iteration of it in
our next book a lot of people use things
oh yeah
like hey cut this whole section i'm like
no this was my one chance
but here's what i'm learning now it's
like no it's not the idea that's wrong
it's my approach toward the idea so i
need to approach it from a different
angle
but what we learned on that tour was how
to approach things from the appropriate
angle i feel like what really resonated
yeah it's interesting how like when i
think about uh
when we went on tour in 2014 and we had
a talk or i had a talk and then you
would read from the book
that was the big tour the biggest one
we've ever done 100 100 cities 119
events but that talk
was an amalgamation of everything we had
done up to that point it was like okay
what's resonating the most with people
what's adding the most value and in fact
i think it was halfway through that tour
that the love people use things uh we we
realized like oh
like the love people use thanks because
the opposite never works is
like you see people like really resonate
with that
um yeah yeah i remember uh starting to
put that at the end of our talk and it's
like
ever since like that's kind of been well
it sums up our message
it does and let me tell you where that
came from initially so we're on tour for
this book here if you're watching the
video version
everything that remains and on the
copyright page
i always like to put a little nugget on
every copyright page
and so right here uh
it just says published by symmetrical
press copyright 2014 by joshua fields
melbourne and ryan nicodemus
all rights reserved love people use
things the opposite never works
like there's just a little tiny message
and that was before that wasn't our
mantra at the time
it wasn't out it was just it was a
little nugget
right like on love people use things the
book there's a little nugget on that on
on that copyright page
as well but i we usually don't talk
about it it's just there for the people
who read the page
but yeah you brought it up about a a
third
a little over a third of the way into
the tour yeah and
you're like hey i think you should
because at one point i said it as an
answer to someone yeah
at the end of an answer like basically
we're just trying to tell you to love
people and use things because the
opposite never works
and all of a sudden it was like you were
like hey i think maybe
i i saw people like really resonate yeah
maybe you should end the events with
them i'm like yeah i'm like dude that
should be the very last line at
every single event